hey guys it is the 21st of April my name
is just McDonald and you attuned int
against what news first up it seems that
a hypothetical sequel to the last of us
may have a different look since bleed
artist has left Naughty Dog Nate Wells
has left the studio to take a job at
giant Sparrow known for making the
unfinished Swan the developer are
currently working on an unannounced game
and one would suppose wealth is attached
to the project this news comes just
weeks after uncharted writer and
creative director Amy Hennig and
uncharted 4 director Justin Richmond
both left the studio do you think this
spells trouble for naughty dog or do you
think this is pretty normals of the game
development industry final where have
released the cover art for Dragon Age
Inquisition and the protagonist appears
to be gender-neutral which makes sense
since he can play as either gender the
cover art of the RPG jus out this fall
features a hero standing on a cliff
about to fight what appears to be a
rather large cloud of feces as for the
lack of gender specification creative
director Mike Laidlaw said an uncertain
gender was absolutely intended it's
whoever you want to roll essentially
Microsoft have said they will win the
console war but they need to do more to
get their head of Xbox Phil Spencer has
promised victory for the xbox one this
generation but specifies definitely in
to win we need to do more that's 100% my
focus so far the Xbox one has been
lagging behind Sony's ps4 a tad since
the latter has sold through 7 million
versus the 5 million plus that Microsoft
have shipped let me know what Microsoft
would have to do or did do to get you to
buy an xbox one over a ps4 for this
console generation set to make some of
us feel very very old the game boy is 25
years old today according to the latest
official numbers 118 point 69 million of
the things have been sold including Game
Boy pocket and Game Boy Color alongside
501 points 11 million pieces of software
comparatively the game
vent released in 2001 sold over 80 1.5
million units let me know what your
favorite all-time handheld console is in
that commenting section down below or
you can chat to me directly on twitter
where i'm at jeff mcdonald those are all
the things that i want to tell you about
today but be sure to send chris some
love for his wonderful hosting duties
and you'll be stuck with me same time
and place tomorrow